there's an eerie emptiness in seversk
the grass is overgrown straight animals
wander the streets
the buildings are burnt out shells of
what they were before the war thousands
of people used to live here few
remains
this man tells us we receive aid but
every day they fire mortars I'm fed up
with it we hear the bang and four
seconds three seconds two seconds they
land
despite the sounds of the shells firing
and Landing people gather to enjoy what
they can of the summer days
solution when the missiles hit we were
here where else would we be we saw the
two clouds rise from two locations
mushroom shape nobody was injured it was
just very powerful and everything sure
it's the little everyday things that
people hold on to here
I have a small gas stove and a small
canister that's how I heat the water I
put the coffee sugar and some special
spices cinnamon it has a good smell soya
says she doesn't want to leave
when people go to other parts of Ukraine
that don't see the war they say you're
from dombas this all happened because of
you go back to dombas why don't you flee
elsewhere but where should we flee some
hostel I live in my own flat my own from
the edge of town you can see Lisa chansk
Russian forces took control of it in
July last year everything in between is
considered too dangerous to visit the
playground is empty There Are No
Children left and just like that the
afternoon peace is shattered gunfire can
be heard as Ukrainian soldiers attempt
to shoot down a drone when you visit
these towns and Villages along the front
line you ask yourself what's left of
these places yes they're a position on a
map and may hold some strategic
significance but most of the buildings
here have either been destroyed or
damaged and most people have left
thank you
and and that gives you an idea of
what this place is going through there's
artillery strikes and there's drones up
in the air
and we can't leave until there's a lull
in the battle
because we don't want to become a Target
I said Big Al Jazeera seversk eastern
Ukraine
in other news scientists say the
destruction of a dam in Ukraine is
causing an environmental catastrophe in
The Wider Black Sea Basin but as this
report from Georgia's Black Sea Resort
of Batumi explains pollution isn't the
only problem Robin Forrester Walker
how's this
Russia's war in Ukraine is hundreds of
kilometers from these bathers in Batumi
on George's Black Sea Coast
yet its effects May soon reach these
Shores
the destruction of Ukraine's kahovka Dam
released up to 180 billion cubic meters
of polluted water satellite data shows a
swirling Bloom of algae feeding on a
sudden discharge of agricultural
nutrients washed off Fields by the flood
waters when it dies it will starve this
ecosystem of oxygen sediment will
deprive it of light the area known as
the Northwestern shelf is a nursery for
many fish species the diops are I expect
will be massive at least in the
Northwestern shelf everything is
connected in the Marine ecosystem so
that's why in my opinion so it will be a
where we can say an ecological
catastrophe
the contamination which includes sewage
and chemicals prompted Odessa to ban
swimming
it is being diluted Bulgaria and Romania
say their beaches are still clean
George's authorities said water quality
Falls within the norm
I don't see any human pollution I
haven't decided if I'm going to swim yet
just a few kilos away from the swimmers
is batumi's municipal waste dump right
on the mouth of a major river
geographically enclosed the Black Sea
has been fed for decades by contaminated
river systems
nature needed a lot more time to restore
the ecosystem before the accident
perhaps 10 years it just might be that
nature no longer has 10 years
pollution may not be a big concern for
most of these holiday makers but the war
has introduced something else into these
Waters something that does pose a small
but very real Danger
this February tourists captured the
moment
a sea mine struck Batumi Beach
it's not known how many may have drifted
from the war zone experts warn kerhovka
may have dislodged plastic
anti-personnel mines
we cannot exclude the possibility that
the current and the Black Sea will bring
them to the Georgian Coast the
population must know that there is a
danger especially children
mankind has already marked the Black Sea
Russia's war in Ukraine is putting more
pressure on this delicate ecosystem
Robin first year Walker Al Jazeera
Batumi